pour la première fois un militant
révolutionnaire à la possibilité de
s'exprimer devant vous cette possibilité
n'est pas le résultat d'une quelconque
élection
cette possibilité n'est pas non plus le
résultat de la bonne volonté de
l'officine de propagande gouvernementale
qui est aujourd'hui le rtm si je peux
m'exprimer aujourd'hui devant vous c'est
grâce à l'extraordinaire mouvement de 10
millions de travailleurs en mai 1968
récemment monsieur marcellin le ministre
de l'intérieur nous expliquer que le
pouvoir était dans les urnes et qu'il
n'était pas dans la rue en fait lorsque
l'on sait comment monsieur marc cela est
devenu ministre de l'intérieur lorsque
l'on sait que le pouvoir gaulliste s'est
institué à l'issue d'un coup d'état
militaire le 13 mai 1958
nous pouvons calmement demandé à
monsieur marc cela si ce pouvoir il l'a
pris par les urnes il l'a pris par les
élections ou si au contraire il n'a pas
utilisé la violence pour devenir
ministre de l'intérieur il est clair que
pour nous jamais la gauche socialiste ne
peut envisager de prendre le pouvoir
d'imposer ses solutions à l'aide des
élections ou à l'aide d'une quelconque
consultations électorales
toutes les expériences vécues en france
ou dans d'autres pays montrent que soit
la gauche- développe un programme de
droite et à ce moment là bénéficient des
voix de droite et peut effectivement
obtenir une majorité gouvernementale
ceux qui aujourd'hui le cas de monsieur
wilson en angleterre ce qui fut le cas
de guy mollet ou mitrand en france mais
lorsque cette gauche développe un
programme beaucoup plus avancé un
programme qui ne peut plus bénéficier du
soutien de la bourgeoisie alors cette
bourgeoisie est prête à violer sa propre
légalité et à imposer ses solutions par
des coups de force militaire on connaît
l'exemple de la grèce et du régime
fasciste qui règne aujourd'hui on
connaît l'exemple de l'indonésie
on connaît aussi l'exemple de l'espagne
public n en fait nous ne faisons
absolument aucune confiance aux
bulletins de vote
nous pensons et mai 68 la montrer que
les travailleurs possèdent leurs propres
moyens de lutte
en mai 68 par des manifestations par des
occupations d usines
les travailleurs ont réussi à imposer ce
qu'aucun bulletin de vote n'avaient pu
faire auparavant
c'est à dire faire reculer le pouvoir
faire reculer l'état faure qu'était
l'état gaulliste en quelques semaines
l'état gaulliste a donné ce qu'il
n'avait jamais accordé en dix ans de
pouvoir
mais pour nous mai 68 ne sera pas un
anniversaire que nous fêterons comme
d'anciens combattants ni un enterrement
ce que s'efforce de faire aujourd'hui la
totalité des partis de la gauche
officielle mais fut pour nous un immense
espoir
est ce que nous nous efforcerons de
faire à travers cette campagne que nous
voulons avant tout une campagne
militante
c'est d'expliquer ce qui s'est passé
durant ces journées c'est d'en tirer
tous les enseignements de montrer toutes
les carences aussi du mouvement de mai
de façon à armer les étudiants les
travailleurs pour les prochaines luttes
qui ne seront pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être des luttes électorales
les enseignements sont extrêmement
nombreux on nous a expliqué pendant des
années qu'il n'y avait plus de classe
ouvrière que le régime capitaliste
néocapitaliste avait résolu toutes ces
contradictions que aujourd'hui il était
capable d'augmenter de façon permanente
le niveau de vie or que voyons nous et
les travailleurs d'ailleurs l'ont vu en
mai 68 il existe des centaines de
milliers de chômeurs il existe
aujourd'hui des dizaines de milliers de
jeunes sans emploi ou lorsqu'ils
trouvent un emploi dans une usine
généralement le trouve pour des tâches
qui ne correspondent pas à leurs
qualifications professionnelles
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises les
cadences augmentent avec la perspective
d'augmentation du profit
en mai 68 par millions les travailleurs
ont pris conscience que le problème
n'était plus de se battre pour telle ou
telle réforme pour deux ou trois
pourcent d'augmentation immédiatement
reprise par le patronat mais qu'il était
nécessaire pour faire aboutir leur
principale revendication de transformer
radicalement la société et de prendre en
main eux mêmes les centres de production
c'est ce qui a commencé à être fait par
les occupations d usines par la mise en
route par les travailleurs eux-mêmes
dans certaines localités des usines mais
sans les patrons une période de
véritable liberté a régné sur la france
pendant ce mais ce mois de mai 1968
à cette époque nous disions que tout
était possible et on nous a traités de
gauchistes d'enragés mais lorsque l'on
regarde de près la situation
lorsqu'on lit tous les ouvrages qui
paraissent aujourd'hui sur cette période
lorsqu'on voit la panique qui régnait
dans les bureaux ministériels déserté
pour la plupart lorsqu'on voit dans quel
état d'isolement se trouvait cette
grande bourgeoisie coupez les
travailleurs couper des étudiants couper
des couches moyennes coupé de la petite
paysannerie
on peut comprendre qu'effectivement à
cette époque si les partis ouvriers
avaient donné une véritable alternative
politique
une alternative socialiste permettant
d'offrir la perspective d'un
gouvernement des travailleurs et donnant
aux travailleurs les moyens de lutte
pour obtenir un tel but alors la
situation aurait complètement changé
alors nous ne nous prononcerons pas
aujourd'hui dans cette période
électorale pour savoir si nous devons
avoir un pompidou ou un poème à la tête
de l'état
aujourd'hui en l'absence de lutte
ouvrière la bourgeoisie apur stabiliser
provisoirement son système elle s'est
même permis le luxe de renvoyer de
gaulle à colombey les deux églises
il est clair que de gaulle a permis en
mai 58 d'assurer un
changement décisif dans les institutions
mais après mais l'instabilité du régime
est apparue de gaulle avait perdu
énormément de prestige et face aux
nouvelles luttes possible et prévisible
la bourgeoisie a compris qu'il était
nécessaire de se séparer de de gaulle
pour envisager un régime capable de
d'affronter la classe ouvrière dans les
mois à venir
deux candidats sauf à nous poey répond
qu'il est pompidou chacun présentant un
programme extrêmement différents comme
vous pouvez en juger
l'un est pour le mouvement dans la
continuité l'autre et pour la continuité
dans le mouvement
voilà la démocratie voilà le choix
décisif qu'on nous impose aujourd'hui
mais ceci est possible parce que face à
ces candidats la gauche officielle
n'offrent aucune alternative
plusieurs candidats se propose mais nous
pouvons leur poser la question où
étiez-vous en mai lorsqu'il ne
s'agissait pas de voter lorsqu'il y
avait ces luttes ouvrières lorsqu'il y
avait ces grèves ou était mollet ou
était de faire ou est un mythe rend
cette question mériterait une réponse
mais je crois que tout le monde déjà peu
la donne et ce combat de mais elle n'a
pas su l'amener aujourd'hui elle se
présente contre la quatrième république
contre le retour à ses moeurs mais
demain de faire me tran mollet et les
autres viendront nous dire il faut
s'opposer
nous sommes contre les moeurs de la vème
république ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est comment avant comment est il
possible d'arriver à une telle situation
un an après mai 68 en fait la gauche vit
sur deux mythes qui la paralyse la
croyance aux bulletins de vote et la
croyance dans cette fameuse union de la
gauche pour nous et nous le disons
clairement nous sommes contre cette
union de la gauche car ce terme ne
recouvrent aujourd'hui absolument plus
rien si la gauche signifie une place
géographique au parlement c'est à dire à
la gauche du président du parlement
alors bien c'est une définition
géographique mais si il s'agit d'un
programme politique
alors nous pouvons poser la question est
ce que lorsque jules moch était ministre
de l'intérieur
et faisait matraquer les mineurs et est
il plus à gauche que marc cela est ce
que guy mollet était un homme de gauche
lorsqu ils envoyaient les parachutistes
à suez est ce que me tran était un homme
de gauche lorsqu'il parlait d' algérie
française
nous ne connaissons pas nous une gauche
nous connaissons une classe ouvrière
nous connaissons des organisations qui
défendent les revendications de la
classe ouvrière mais nous ne pouvons pas
aller au delà
l'union qui est nécessaire à l'heure
actuelle pour aboutir à une
transformation radicale de la société
c'est l'union de tous les travailleurs
permettant par la suite une alliance de
la classe ouvrière unis sur un programme
socialiste avec les couches moyennes
nous nous refusons quant à nous à
rentrer dans ce jeu des politiciens de
gauche quel qu'il soit mai 68 a fait
apparaître en france un nouveau courant
communiste courant communiste pour qui
le socialisme n'est tout à fait autre
chose que la caricature qui existent
aujourd'hui en union soviétique pour lui
pour nous le socialisme ce n'est pas les
camps de concentration pour nous le
socialisme ça ne peut pas être un régime
qui met comme en union soviétique
des intellectuels en prison qui empêche
toute démocratie ouvrière qui n'hésite
pas à rétablir ce qu'il appelle la
légalité d'un pays frère en envoyant des
troupes d'occupation comme cela a été
fait en tchécoslovaquie
ce nouveau communisme ce nouveau courant
d'avant garde n'existe pas seulement en
france il existe à l'heure actuelle dans
toute une série de pays d'europe
d'amérique latine et même aux états unis
ce socialisme aujourd'hui n'est pas
incarnée par brejnev ou kossyguine mais
beaucoup plus incarné par che guevara et
nous pensons que mai 68 rend tout à fait
actuel la fameuse phrase de che guevara
le devoir de tout révolutionnaire et de
faire la révolution
lorsque l'on voit comment les occasions
ont pu être manqué en 36 en 1946 47 et
récemment en 1968
nous nous apercevons et il est clair
aujourd'hui que le titre de communisme
ne se mérite pas en achetant une carte
ce n'est pas un monopole d'un parti ces
petites re qui se mérite
à travers la participation aux actions
de la classe ouvrière
c'est un titre qui se gagne dans la
lutte de classe en ce qui nous concerne
nous nous envisageons à travers cette
campagne électorale de rendre compte du
combat mené en mai par 10 millions de
travailleurs et de donner les moyens de
le poursuivre
[Musique]